well tactical voting could be key in
these final 24 hours before the polls
over many voters frustrated that in the
UK's electoral system there are many
constituencies where their votes may not
actually make any difference
so tactical voting has become a big
factor in this particular election
opponents of the Conservatives have
cited it as possibly the only way to
defeat them on the most high-profile
examples is the actor Steve Coogan he's
a longtime Labour supporter he's been
campaigning over the last few days for
the Liberal Democrats in his own
constituency Napoli's to say that Steve
joins me now Steve Coogan is in our
central London studio Steve good
afternoon to you good afternoon you're
facing well a figure an easy choice but
for many other voters it will be a
difficult choice as you said a lifelong
labour support of voting Lib Dem in this
election you're asking people to vote
against you know the long-held beliefs
and parties they believe in yes I am but
I think this election is unique it's not
like any other because I think the
future of the country is at stake in a
way that's matters more than it has in
the last 50 to 70 years there's a lurch
to the right across Europe a right-wing
populism and I think this concurrent
Conservative government is party to that
rise and is a particularly pernicious
form of Conservative government they
even many conservative one nation whose
services find alien to them like a lord
hassle time kind of talk and John Major
to name a handful have been punished for
going against the party line it's it's a
unique situation so we're asking people
yes to for this one occasion to suspend
their normal party loyalties because
there are bigger things at stake so
expecting if you what we're asking
people is if you're in a marginal Tory
constituency who's the main contender if
the main contender is a Liberal
Democrats vote Liberal Democrat the main
contender is labour vote Labour and we
say we're repeating as people in the
Labour Party Liberal Democrats and even
those One Nation conservatives who you
know whose party has been frankly rested
from them by these right-wing
I'd say fundamentalist politicians who
prey on people's prejudices and appeal
to the worst side of human nature and
they need to be hobbled
if there are conservative voters out
there who will be voting conservative
perhaps because they've always voted
conservative perhaps because what's that
in that manifesto appeals to them it
benefits their me benefits their family
it benefits their job they'll be going
out tomorrow and voting in good faith
it's quite uncomfortable for them to
think that their vote might not count
because others are gaming the system the
well lord Hesseltine has made it quite
clear he'll be voting liberal now he's a
conservative of great integrity even
though I disagree with him politically
he's someone who has what we might call
used to be called common decency and is
something that the old conservative
party even though I disagree with them
had this current conservative an
administration Rives rush roughshod
through those things it plays fast and
loose with the fact Boris Johnson is not
a principled politician the day before
the referendum he wrote two articles one
in favor of brexit one against brexit so
clearly has no ideological commitment
he's just interested in one thing that's
the preservation of his career he's not
a man of principle but this is against
Boris Johnson obviously you're part of
this movement that is for anyone but
Boris Johnson but what about local
Conservative candidates who in their
constituency are making a real
difference to people's lives they could
lose out people could see this is
disingenuous and when we're putting
pressure on politicians to be truthful
you've highlighted that yourself people
are going to the polls and lying with
their vote no people are going to the
polls trying to change the direction in
this country because there are more
important things than even local party
politics at this stage we need to stop
this government in its tracks it's not
the Ritz not even the traditional kind
of Conservative government and the only
way to do that is to vote liberal and if
you're a liberal marginal or labor and
labor marginal there are bigger things
afoot and so you know it's time to sort
of change things and stop this this
lurch to the right that's happening
across Europe is the most pernicious
thing it's it's something that needs to
be halted see you big hairy very clear
anyone but Boris Johnson you're voting
Liberal Democrat when you're a Labour
supporter as part of this tactical
voting movement that you know one in
three voters say they're considering
doing it websites of crash today people
are taking an interest in this in the
build-up to tomorrow but what do you
want to see the government look
on Friday because we've been mentioning
the polls are narrowing we could end up
with a hung parliament which takes us
back to square one if Labour get in and
it's a minority other leaders have said
they're very clear they won't work with
him and all the other opposition parties
are so different labour like full for
sugarcoat Lib Dem like Diet Coke do you
see what I mean it's a very difficult
situation for people I think the most
important thing is to stop this push
over a cliff there's that it's
dog-whistle politics Boyce Johnson
thinks that if we if we leave then
everything's going to be fine fine and
dandy this is a magic silver bullet it's
not we're in a mess the whole country's
divided if we leave if we leave in you
know in a few months time with the Boris
Johnson government we'll still have all
the problems because it's a very
divisive extreme measure the only route
this message for cross party agreement
where we dig ourselves out of this mess
slowly day by day there's no magic
silver bullet okay see if I do you have
to ask about your motivation for this is
this brexit related for you in terms of
there was a referendum it ended up in
the vote leave is that what you want to
see happen on Friday a party get in that
will either offer a second referendum or
to revoke article 50 is that what you'd
like to see I think it goes beyond best
of me it's about how we treat our fellow
human beings and as I said I think
there's a kind of a consensus across
party consensus of of politicians and
voters who don't like the smell of this
Labor government it's the nasty party
it's pretty encouraging prejudicial
exploits people's ignorance and people's
fears and insecurities in the worst
possible way so so the appeal is and
there's a consensus about this of people
who think that this is a different kind
of politics and we want to get back to
the politics of consensus and the
politics of decency
that is my overriding concern beyond
even the brexit or romaine question okay
Steve I'm really interested to hear from
you today thank you very much for your
time steve coogan who's been out and
about campaigning with the Liberal
Democrats in his constituency as part of
this tactical voting campaign a lot of
people very interested in that let me
know what you think at Sky News hashtag
SJM shows it's something that you've
into perhaps you think it may work in
your constituency as I said a lot of
websites have crashed today with people
finally making up their mind ahead of
going out to vote tomorrow